[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce soir c'est jean luc mélenchon de
commencer et puis ah bah voilà
abbas est déjà là quoi
aller au boulot sous des dehors déjà au
boulot ça commence bien ah bah ouais
ce qu'il faut c'est déprimant
bonjour astel
[Musique]
koukougnon
vous devez voter à issel non on est en
plein débat et pourtant on était en
plein débat avec daniel riolo martin
bourdin qui m'a dit mettons oreillettes
et il a bien raison
et benjamin amar ben oui et on était en
débat dans l'émission on se chauffait
c'était un warm up pour nous il ne vous
entend pas par contre
c'est vraiment un mais regardez mon dos
ne
s'était pas prévu mais c'est comme ça on
est en direct voyez gens les prennent un
choc il débattra également c'est que moi
je l'enlève pour l'émission tandis que
il lagarde dont les ordres évidemment
sous-ordre
[Rires]
si on regarde plus au nord on a dit
youtube ici pour les politiques c'est le
grand désert seuls deux oasis celle des
insoumis au sud et des extrêmes au nord
offre aux candidats un cadre accueillant
c'est le cas pour mélenchon mais aussi
pour filippo et zemmour qui ont su y
trouver leur public pour tous les autres
c'est le réseau du flop total notamment
pour anne hidalgo dont la chaîne ne
compte que 64 abonnés
c'est sa chaîne officielle avec les
petits tics et toi
changé parce qu'elle est venue en pyjama
mais vous verrez vous verrez quand même
qu'il ya du public tout autour il ya
l'idée du
saf et sa fille mme merkel ce mode de
maintenu je vais dire un mot pardon
alors j'ai appelé madame pauline de
malherbe parce que je veux pas qu'il y
ait de malentendu moi je répondre sur le
même ton il n'y a aucune attaque
personnelle c'était une interview
manifestement entendu c'était une
interview manifestement qui empêchait
parler du fond sans doute un peu des
deux côtés je le pense les manifestants
j'ai pas réussi non plus à passer les
messages de fonds qui étaient des
questions de sécurité
je fais lui turkstat elle peut-être
or par toi tu as toi c'est un signe de
méthyle routière s'appliquent en tient
un abruti comme ça dont on pouvait pas
rouler on fait quoi je termine une fusée
derrière larmes ans
ça va bien se passer c'est une
expression extrêmement populaire moi je
ne parle pas le langage techno fait une
fixation qui fait surgir des souvenirs
ou des moments très traumatisant chez
les femmes malheureusement ça va bien
une excellente jeu l'utilisent de très
nombreuses fois à l'assemblée nationale
d'ailleurs contre monsieur bernalicis
eux puisque beaucoup de vos consoeurs et
confrères ont ressorti pour savoir si
j'avais déjà sorties précédentes
oui vous m'avez dit vous avez pris le
risque de faire mourir des gens je la
connais ont pas de moyens des gens à
ne pas les installer sur deux 42% des
guadeloupéens snow d'amour qui seront
vaccinés depuis 12 ans alors que sur
l'ensemble de la france et 4 voilà alors
il fallait que j'aille que je leur dise
madame lapix m'a dit de vous dire que
c'est pas bien les enfants vous savez
pas ce que vous faites parce que il se
trouve écoutez madame c'est pas comme ça
qu'on fait faites votre boulot chez
aaa
german a parlé avec la gauche non le ton
vous avez utilisé était condescendant
été jugés sexistes été jugé ce niveau j
c'est à mon avis tout à fait faux et ce
qui à mon avis est sexiste et misogyne
c'est pas considérer que lorsqu'on a un
interlocuteur selon qu'elle soit une
femme ou un homme on doit utiliser des
mots différents j'ai été me semble-t-il
me semble-t-il tout à fait dans le ton
d'une interview tendu qui était sans
doute pas très agréable à écouter même à
vivre il faut bien l'avouer les regarde
qui est en train de te mettre la regarde
quant à 12 palette la lui lâchant rien
pourquoi il fait ça j'en sais rien
une bonne tête de vainqueur
oui c'est moi une bagnole
c'est moins d'efforts dans my bones et
mauvaises sont super agressif et
détendez-vous élégant mouassa mesures
rien ok mais que je te vois pas ce que
je peux te toucher
évidemment évidemment voilà voilà
et j'ai deux pieds c'est original
ouais mais tu as pas des grands pieds
s'y sont pas trompés non tout est bien
proportionné
jean marc qui m'a dit l'important c'est
de bien de tenir le manche à sigean mac
lundi l'équilibré pourquoi que
l'appareil se met sur le côté donc il
faut voilà c'est un peu d'expression
mais tombait à tenir le manche
d'une compagnie aérienne de las vegas
veut aider les couples à se faire des
petits câlins dans les airs eh oui si
vous passez par las vegas sachez que
pour un peu moins de 900 euros la
compagnie l'offre cloud vient vous
chercher en limousine avec son pilote
fans de pizza margherita comme en
témoigne son tatouage
à l'intérieur de l'avion tout est fait
pour faire monter la température avec
des bouquets de fleurs des coussins en
forme de coeur et même un rouleau de
sopalin
[Musique]
ah non
alors
[Musique]
merci
non
c'est le nom
la fin
non ça va pas la ténue
mais je n'y peux rien moi j'aurai mes
amis tous vous faire ben on n'y arrivera
pas tant messi non non non tu as rendu
trop loin tu peux non feinte et à droite
et non pas les dérives on dérive mais
j'avais
alors non se moque pas l'erreur est
fréquenté petit rappel afin d'éviter que
ça se reproduise la police nazie c'est
la gestapo qui n'a rien à voir avec le
gaspacho qui lui est un potage espagnol
après cette confusion entre le célèbre
potage espagnole et la police politique
du troisième reich les internautes ont
pu s'en délecter et même la principale
concernée a fini par prendre les choses
avec autodérision en restant dans le
thème de la soupe pas de sous pour ceux
qui espionnent illégalement les membres
du congrès mais ils seront jetés au
goulasch honda
[Applaudissements]
j'étais trempé genre j'ai le cul 30 et
après qu'est ce qu'on fait
[Musique]
on avait tombé de bord énumérons pas
comme ça les gens ne sont pas près
d'arriver